that song is so different from human
speech that it barely scrapes the limits
of our hearing
but babies and fat pups have a lot in
common when it comes to their early
chattering new research has revealed
vocalizing behaviors that both these
mammals share in infancy
it's a first of its kind comparison the
scientists say that defines baby bat
babbling
babies make distinct sounds and often
repeat them ad nauseum
they're part of babbling a crucial rung
on the ladder to spoken language greater
sackwing bats don't speak but their
buzzes appeal to potential mates their
pups get started early past studies show
they rattle off sounds resembling adult
territorial songs which help males court
mates and defend their turf
that makes them among a few mammals like
marmosets whose offspring utter sound
similar to babbling in babies
researchers thought these bat pup chirps
might share some features with human
babbling but no one knew for sure
first the researchers had to pin down
what the sound shared with those made by
human infants they defined eight
elements of babbling based on studies in
humans
these included how old babies are when
they start babbling what sounds and
syllables babies use and why they use
these sounds even when they seem to have
no clear purpose
the researchers observed bat colonies on
buildings and trees in central america
and recorded their vocalizations in
different contexts they might note when
a pup made its first chirps
another pup might repeat the same vocal
pattern over and over with no response
from its parent as babies sometimes do
next came the arduous task of
classifying the vocal patterns of bat
pups
since baby gurgles and coos are familiar
and audible to us
the different sounds they make are
easier to tell apart but many bat sounds
fall outside the range of normal human
hearing and are nothing like the
language we're used to so bat vocal
patterns must be identified visually by
hunting for signature shapes in their
sound waves
scientists log thousands of sounds from
200 plus babbling bouts and sorted them
into syllables
that required manually matching the
visual shapes of sound waves to 25 types
of adult bat syllables
eventually they assembled a library of
back calls that resembled human babbling
like babies the bat pups produced long
strings of sounds made of the basic
structures of adult sounds they also had
their own rhythms just like baby babbles
have distinct cadences and the features
of these sounds were found in every bat
colony the way that all babies babble
regardless of language or culture
in the future the researchers hope to
learn more about why little bats chatter
in the first place the same group has
begun studying genes that in humans
relate to language if similar genes are
active in bat brains during both
babbling and language acquisition it
could mean that these early bat
vocalizations are simply the warm-up
sessions for fully developed bat songs
the way baby babbling is a precursor to
human speech
bats may be echoing the evolution of
human communication
even if it's just out of earshot
[Music]